>> AND NOW, THE ULTIMATE HOME.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE ALONE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THESE LUXURY
LIVING PODS WHICH FLOAT ON
STEEL TUBES, THREE METERS ABOVE
THE SURFACE OF THE WATER.
THEY CAUGHT BETWEEN $295,000 ON
ONE POINT $5 MILLION A PIECE.
AND THEY ARE CURRENTLY UNDER
CONSTRUCTION IN THE CLINTON BAY
MARINA ON THE NORTH COAST OF
PANAMA.
THE COMPANY BEHIND IT, CALLED
OCEAN BUILDERS, HOPES TO
DISTRIBUTE THEM INTERNATIONALLY
ONCE IT'S CONFIDENT THE
TECHNOLOGY CAN BE SUPPORTED
ELSEWHERE.
YOU GET 73 SQUARE METERS OF
LIVING SPACE AND ONE OF THESE
THINGS.
YOU GET PANORAMIC WINDOWS.
AND THEY COME LOADED WITH
TECHNOLOGY.
THE TECHNOLOGY SAYS, IF YOU RUN
OUT OF MILK, HEY, DRONES WILL
DELIVER SMALL ITEMS.
AS FOR TAKING OUT THE GARBAGE,
LARGER AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES WILL
DO THAT JOB.
THE COMPANY HAS ALSO DEVISED A
MODEL FOR USE ON LAND.
GRANT VERMONT IS THE CEO OF
OCEAN BUILDERS AND I AM SO
EXCITED TO TALK WITH YOU ABOUT
THESE SUPER COOL, SCI-FI
LOOKING PODS.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
>> THANK YOU, ALISON.
GREAT TO BE HERE.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT WITH THE
OPTIONS ARE FOR THOSE WHO WANT
TO BUY ONE OF THESE THINGS.
THERE IS ONE BUILT FOR AQUATIC,
LIVING ONE FOR LAND AND A THIRD
FOR WHAT YOU CALL A MORE
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY
OPTION.
IS THERE A CERTAIN PERSON WHO
CAN ACTUALLY HANDLE THIS KIND
OF LIVING?
TALK US THROUGH WHO THE RIGHT
PERSON IS TO BUY ONE OF THESE
AND LIVE IN ONE OF THESE.
>> YOU KNOW, I WAS ORIGINALLY
LIVING IN A FLOATING HOME ABOUT
THREE AND A HALF YEARS AGO IN
TORONTO.
IT LOOKED LIKE A NORMAL HOUSE
BUT IT WAS ON A FLOATING
CONCRETE BARGE.
EVERYONE THAT CAME TO VISIT
JUST FELL IN LOVE WITH THE
LIFESTYLE.
I FOUND THAT PEOPLE WHO WOULD
NEVER THINK ABOUT LIVING ON THE
WATER JUST FELL IN LOVE WITH IT
AND I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW IT
EXISTED UNTIL I STAYED THERE AS
A ONE NIGHT AIRBNB.
THEN I EXTENDED FOR A WEEK AND
THEN A MONTH AND THEN THE
SUMMER AND THEN I DIDN'T LEAVE
FOR MANY YEARS.
SO, NOW I HAVE COME HERE TO
PANAMA TO BUILD WHAT I BELIEVE
IS THE WORLD'S MOST
TECHNOLOGICALLY ADVANCED
FLOATING HOME.
AND MAYBE THE MOST ADVANCED
HOME ON LAND AS WELL.
SO --
GO AHEAD, FINISH YOUR THOUGHT.
>> I THINK THE MARKET FOR THIS
IS PRETTY MUCH ANYONE THAT I
CAN GET ON A SEA PART FOR JUST
A FEW MINUTES.
BECAUSE THE VIEWS ARE JUST
STUNNING.
AND I THINK PEOPLE WOULD LOVE
THE LIFESTYLE.
>> I WANT TO GO THROUGH SOME OF
THE SUSPECTS AT THE LITTLE BIT
MORE.
WHAT IS THE AQUATIC ONE
ATTACHED TO?
HOW FAR INTO THE OCEAN IS IT
SITTING AND CAN YOU INSTALL
THESE ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD?
>> THE PIED ITSELF, WE CALL IT
C PIED.
THE FLOATING VERSION IN THE
WATER.
IT'S KIND OF AN OPTICAL
ILLUSION.
IT LOOKS LIKE A POST --
IT GOES RAIN TO THE SEA FLOOR.
THE WHOLE HOUSE THIS FLOATING
SO HIGH ABOVE THE WATER DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE IT IS.
BUT IT ACTUALLY IS FLOATING.
IT CAN BE A MINIMUM OF FIVE
METERS OF WATER, AND A MAXIMUM
OF 200 METERS.
>> WHAT'S IF THERE IS A BIG
STORM THAT'S COMING OR A BIG
WAVE?
IS IT BEING HELD STEADY THAT
MUCH THAT IT CAN SUSTAIN THAT
SORT OF FORCE?
>> WE'RE ENGINEER FOR WAYS OF
UP TO FIVE METERS.
AND IF WE WANTED TO ENGINEER
FOR LARGER WAVES WE COULD.
WE ARE GOING TO START A TESTING
PROJECT NEXT YEAR IN FLORIDA
WHERE WE ARE GOING TO TRY TO
INCH NEAR FOR HURRICANE
CONDITIONS.
IF WE CAN CRACK THAT THAT, I
THINK THIS WILL BE REALLY
POPULAR IN FLORIDA.
ABOUT 40% OF OUR GLOBAL
UNMANNED AND INQUIRIES IS
COMING FROM FLORIDA.
I THINK IS A HUGE MARKET FOR
THESE BEAR.
BUT RIGHT NOW, WE STARTED IN
PANAMA BECAUSE WE'RE OUTSIDE OF
HURRICANE ZONE HERE.
IT MAKES THINGS EASY.
>> WHAT ABOUT ELECTRICITY?
AND ALSO SECURITY?
PILOTS?
IT'S GONNA TAKE A LONG TIME, IF
YOU HAVE AN ISSUE IN YOUR POD,
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A LONG, TIME
I WOULD THINK, FOR SECURITY TO
GET WHERE YOU ARE TO HELP YOU.
>> WELL, WE ARE STARTING AT A
PLACE THAT'S REALLY CLOSE TO
THE MARINA.
SO WE HAVE ALL OF THE --
WE'RE CLOSE TO CONVENE STORIES,
AND SECURITY AS WELL.
BUT THIS IS A PRETTY SECURE
AREA.
BUT WE CAN ALSO HAVE AERIAL
DRONES DELIVERING AND COME OUT
AND DO SURVEILLANCE.
AND MAKE SURE EVERYTHING SAFE.
WE ALSO HAVE SOMETHING WE'VE
BUILT CALLED BOTH AI.
IT IS A CAMERA THAT IS PLACED
DIFFERENT POINTS A DIFFERENT
PART OF THE PART, WE CAN SEE
FOR SEVERAL MILES AND SEVERAL
DIRECTIONS.
WE CAN CONNECT IT TO AN AI
ALGORITHM THAT CAN DETECT THOSE
AND FRIENDLIER UNKNOWN BOATS
HEADING DIRECTLY OR WAY.
SO YOU CAN HAVE LOTS OF NOTICE
OF THOSE ISSUES.
>> FULL DISCLOSURE, I NEED TO
TAKE DRAMAMINE WHEN I GO ON A
BOAT.
HOW DO YOU NOT GET SEASICK ON
ONE OF THESE?
>> WELL, THE CHALLENGE WITH
MOST BOTH IS THAT THE FLOATING
PART THAT YOU'RE ACTUALLY IN
ITS FLOATING IN THE WAVE LINE.
AND, SO OUR HOMES, THEY ARE
FLOATING SEVERAL METERS ABOVE
THE --
AND THEN THE FLOTATION, WHICH
IS UNDER THE, WATER IS UNDER
THE WAVE LINE.
WE'RE ACTUALLY SKIPPING THE
WHOLE WAVE SECTION, WHICH IS
WHERE THAT MOVEMENT COMES FROM.
AND THERE'S ONLY A 1.6 METER
DIAMETER POLL THAT IS CONNECTED
--
CONNECTING THE TWO.
THE WAVES ARE INTERACTING WITH
A VERY SMALL PIECE OF MATERIAL,
VERSUS ENTIRE BOW.
SO INSTEAD OF THE BOAT MOVING
AROUND IN THE WAVES, WERE
FLOATING ABOVE THE WAVES.
>> AND VERY QUICKLY, I'M
CURIOUS HOW MANY OF THESE
FUTURISTIC PARTS YOU NEED TO
SELL TO TURN A PROFIT COFFEE.
>> WELL, WE'RE GOING TO DO SOME
RE-FACTORING FOR MANUFACTURING
TO GET THE COST DOWN.
RIGHT NOW, WE'VE BEEN BUILDING
OUR PROTOTYPES, WHICH HAVE BEEN
AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF WORK.
IT'S BEEN A HUGE PROJECT.
WE'VE HAD ABOUT 80 PEOPLE
WORKING, OR UP TO 80 PEOPLE
WORKING FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS
TO BUILD THIS TECHNOLOGY.
AND THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY
COMPLEX THING.
NOTHING LIKE IT HAS EVER BEEN
DONE BEFORE.
THERE IS MARINE ENGINEERING.
THERE IS SOFTWARE, HARDWARE AND
MATERIAL SCIENCE.
AND SO MANY THINGS THAT NEED TO
COME TOGETHER TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN.
THAT IS BEEN A HUGE PROJECT.
SO WE NEED TO GET OUR
MANUFACTURING UP.
BUT BASICALLY, WE JUST DID OUR
LAUNCH A WEEK AGO TODAY.
AND --
OUR ONLINE LAUNCH.
AND THE RE